I decided that I was going to tell the
story because it's a story that needs to
be told luckiest girl alive is a
carefully cast personal story that was
brought to life from The New York Times
best-selling novel of the same name we
are digging into all the behind the
scenes secrets that make this film so
incredibly powerful number one Mila
Kunis helped shape the ending of the
film after being sent to the script Mila
Kunis realized that she'd actually read
and loved the book years prior Jessica
Knoll was thrilled to have Mila step
into the shoes of her main character
this could have so easily gone sideways
if it was anybody else not just anyone
can do this when Mila started reading
through the ending there were a lot of
conversations about how it just wasn't
Landing it ended with Jessica Knoll
pulling even more from her real-life
experiences to craft an ending that felt
more emotionally linear to the movie's
message Mila fought for the film's
ending although not everyone agreed with
it so many people had such a different
experience while watching the same piece
of content including the ending a lot of
people didn't like it but I fought so
hard for it to stay in I'm really glad
that we won this fight because it's so
powerful number two Kiara Aurelia was
stoked to collaborate with Mila Kunis I
was a huge milagunas fan before I ever
attached myself to the movie obviously I
mean everyone is the two actors were
extremely passionate about their roles
and did a ton of Zoom meetings before
the film even started shooting to go
over their characters she spent a lot of
time kind of you know talking with me
and talking about you know mannerisms
and voice and the sound they really
wanted to be on the same page about who
Annie was going to be and how she would
behave not only with her actions but
with her voice and Body Language number
three one of the only things Jessica
Knoll was extremely particular about
when it came to telling her story
Jessica allowed the cast and crew to
have a lot of artistic Liberties because
not everything can be translated from
real life life to the screen but when it
came to wardrobe it was a different
story she was very specific on the look
of the people like she wanted Finn's
character to look a very specific way
the reason behind this was because the
look of these characters was taken from
actual people that Jessica knew in the
past so she was much more involved in
wardrobe than we than most people
probably think number four actors often
create their own backstories for their
characters the back of my scripts would
have a whole fictitious background of a
character Mila Kunis revealed that with
every character she plays she creates
her own backstory to that character's
life things that the audience would
never know or find out about oh I have a
whole other story I myself write a whole
like story and thoughts and ideas
throughout her career this has helped
her turn characters that would otherwise
be considered one-dimensional into
thoughtful real people as long as I have
an understanding of why they are the way
that they are you know I I always
thought the most vulnerable you'll ever
see a person is from behind than
anything think is possible number five
this movie deals with some really heavy
stuff Mila Kunis after spending long
working days in the shoes of Annie
Finelli needed to take care of her own
mental health when she got off the clock
I happen to have an incredible partner
that is fully aware of what my job
entails she's talking of course about
her husband Ashton Kutcher who knows
better than anyone how much of a strain
acting can take on your mental
well-being he proved to be pivotal in
her ability to unwind and take a step
back from the heavy Narrative of
luckiest girl alive he made dinner and
if I got home super late he'd have a
plate in the microwave that I can just
press number six there were a lot of
workarounds to get this movie made
because the film was shot during Peak
covid they weren't able to do any
rehearsals in person they were all over
Zoom the movie was shot mostly in Canada
with the exteriors shot in New York but
getting into Canada at that time proved
to be a major challenge the only reason
Milo got to collaborate with her co-star
Kiara was because she was a producer on
the film I was able to watch the dailies
every day and so I got to see all of her
performance and pick up on like little
things the two of them hardly ever got
to meet up in person because of the
restrictions covet placed on production
the easiest thing for her to do was
bring those little things she saw in her
performance into her own depiction of
the character number 7. Jessica Knowles
started writing this script in 2015
being new to filmmaking at the time she
didn't expect there to be so many drafts
there are so many people who are a part
of this project who need to be able to
sign off it she had to go from the
director to Mila Kunis to the executives
and to the producers with each draft
hoping for a green light the hardest
thing is throwing really good material
away throughout the process Jessica had
to cut so much of what people would
still consider a ton of great writing
number eight the comment that won
everyone over director Mike Barker
Jessica Knoll and Mila Kunis all met for
the first time on Zoom as sort of an
introductory call it was basically a way
for Jessica and Mike to decide if they
wanted Mila to work on the project with
them Mila recently watched a ton of
Mike's previous films and her comment on
them was what made the two of them fall
in love with her my cat a tendency to
work on really hard beautiful stories
but they were ultimately really sad and
not for everybody and not always
palatable so I was like Mike you're
really depressing they were both really
impressed by her bold statement and
wanted to continue to work with her from
then on number nine over 1500 people
auditioned to play the high school
version of Annie when Jessica Knowles
saw Kiara's audition she knew right away
that she was the one for the role I saw
there was such a vulnerability about her
that was so beautiful to me and so
necessary for this character but also
you could tell there was spunk there
which we needed this character very much
to have when Chiara landed the role she
had an introductory Zoom call with
Jessica and Mila she was absolutely
Terror terrified but found the women to
be so nice and supportive they developed
an incredible working relationship
together throughout the duration of the
film number 10. the process of bringing
the character to the screen came with
major changes and the biggest thing that
we had to do was to separate Jess from
the character when it came to writing
the novel Jessica Knoll mainly did that
entire process alone but when it came to
creating the film it was so
collaborative that Mike and Mila ended
up having major input on Annie's new
character and in turn the ending of the
film as far as I put the North Star for
the character it very much is the ending
number 11 she described herself as cheap
labor on the project I can't imagine
anyone else touching this considering
this book was based on Jessica Noel's
own trauma writing it became a way for
her to process and heal after over a
year of struggling to put the words to
paper and I think also a big part of it
was like a lot of my own story is
embedded one day I just sat down and the
voice of Annie Finelli just poured out
of me and it was non-stop for the next
eight months until the book was was
completed the studio allowed her to have
free reign over her own story as she
continued to pull from her real-life
experiences to shape it into something
that truly resonated with its audience
number 12 sometimes the darkest events
make for the most important Stories the
inspiration behind this novel is not a
happy one but what really sparked the
story was how Jessica was treated in the
aftermath of it so I was really you know
blamed and shamed
um and and really silent when she
confided in a doctor and even tried to
confront one of her attackers nobody
believed her people just were like no
it's just too complicated this story was
really important when it came to
overcoming the silence that was forced
upon her that's not what happened it was
a party it got out of hand and continues
to help thousands of people have the
courage to share their own stories and
process similar traumas they have faced
with an All-Star cast a dedicated crew
and writer the film luckiest girl alive
proves to be an incredibly success
successful collaborative personal
narrative that speaks volumes to people
who have often felt powerless when it
came to telling their own stories